This channel has reached 200k subscribers so as
per tradition I am doing another QnA video. In
July I asked people on the YouTube community
tab for questions and you have delivered. I
sadly cannot answer all of them because this
video would be like hours long if I did. There
were also some very tough questions that for me
to answer properly and in a way where I would be
satisfied with my answers I would have to dedicate
an entire video to answering it and I sadly didn’t
have time for that, so I apologize.
With that aside, let's begin.
------------------------------------------------------------
@iamapotatoinlovewithblonde4518
What is your favorite paradox game ?
Have you ever tried doing a mega campaign ?
Hands down my favorite paradox game is
EU4, I have almost 1,500 hours in it. If
that game didn’t exist I am willing
to bet I would probably upload more
because there are definitely times when
I should be working but I am not because
I am playing EU4 … It’s a problem 😅
I never tried doing a mega campaign
because even though I own and have played all
the other paradox games, for whatever reason I
don’t like them as much as eu4 and so if I want
to play a grand strategy game I just play eu4.
-----------------------------------------
@darawkay4021
Do you have any
plans to make videos similar to
"Life of a Hanseatic Merchant"?
Ok, let me tell you, I had lots of problems
with that video. When you’re doing a life of
an X kind of person in history, there’s a lot of
historical nuance that gets lost and there’s also
usually a lot of guesswork that’s being made.
This is mainly because our sources are varied,
they are a combination of many things, from
official histories, to surviving inscriptions,
to administrative documents, to
mentions in third party writings,
etc. This varied and limited nature of the
sources, especially for classical and middle ages,
naturally often paints an incomplete picture which
then doesn’t translate well into trying to present
a complete life of a historical character kind
of story. There’s just too many unknowns. For
example, all the hazing information we have about
the Bergen Contor comes from outsiders laughing at
how ridiculous it is. Therefore, we don’t have a
complete picture of it, nor do we know the hazing
I described was something recurring or it just
happened to be the type of hazing they did that
specific year that we have the source from. We
have other sources from different times mentioning
there was hazing but we don’t know if the hazing
was always the same. Not to mention that as I say
in the video the life of a Hanseatic merchant
changed over time as the league existed for
hundreds of years and trying to present a coherent
single story from just one decade is impossible
because a lot of the surviving sources span a
century. The sources describing the recruitment
might have been from 1404 while the surviving
administrative documents might have been from 1491
while the hazing source could have been from 1444,
etc. A lot can happen in a hundred years and,
therefore, after I finished that video I kind of
realized that presenting this story of the life
of an “average” 14th century Hanseatic merchant is
misleading. Not to mention that even if we find a
diary of a Hanseatic merchant from that time whose
to say his story was the quote unquote “average”.
These kinds of “life of an X” stories are just
often misleading and present a sort of uniformity
in past people’s lives that just didn’t exist.
I still published the video because I think it’s
good and funny and I do emphasize the nuances
about the fact that a lot of people could have
had a very different experience as merchants in
the Hanseatic league compared to what I presented,
and nothing I said in the video was made up,
it’s still all in the sources, but doing such a
video I think loses the context of the sources and
historical nuance and therefore I am reluctant to
do another video like that. This doesn’t mean you
cannot make a good video in this sort of style,
but it has to be a topic where we have
far more sources surviving, especially
personal sources like diaries. So I guess in
a long winded way my answer is, probably not,
and if yes it would be about something far better
documented than the life of a hanseatic merchant.
----------------------------------------------------------------
@ChessedGamon
Do you travel
much? Are there any notable places you've
been to and what did you think of them?
Ehh, I don’t like traveling that much, it
gives me anxiety. I overthink too much about
everything that can go wrong from my backpack
being stolen to losing my passport somewhere
to even being pulled over at the airport
because they thought I was a Russian spy,
which did happen to me once in
a Florida airport, true story.
With that said, ironically, despite not liking
to travel, I have traveled a lot in my life,
but I have not seen much. Let me explain, I used
to play tennis on an ITF level, so I traveled
a lot for tennis tournaments but oftentimes I
would just see the hotel and the tennis courts,
so even though I have been to many countries, I
have not seen anything in those countries other
than the hotel and the tennis courts. But ever
since I stopped playing tennis I have tried to
remedy that, so even though I don’t like traveling
I try to force myself to travel when I can because
I do enjoy some aspects of travel, like getting
to hike in different places or visiting historical
sights. Most recently I went to southern Spain
to look at places like Ronda and Alhambra. I
am a sucker for mountains and water features so
Alhambra was like a perfect place for me to visit,
it was amazing, I definitely recommend visiting.
My next plan is to visit Scandinavia so we’ll see
when or if that happens, it all depends on if I
can get some good cheap deals on things and even
then it always takes me a while just to convince
myself to go since I stress about traveling.
------------------------------------------------------------------
@bagel3703
What popular
period of historical study
is overrated in your opinion?
Everyone knows the answer to this, say it with
me, WW2. I mean, if you go to a random bookstore
and look into the history books section,
half of the books are always WW2 related.
People have just this weird obsession with it
which I never understood because I personally
don’t find it that interesting. I think it’s
like the same concept as with horror movies,
people have this weird interest in all the
terrible stuff that happened and because it
really happened there’s this weird maccarb
curiosity. I think it’s the same idea why
people seemed to be so interested in
Aztecs and their human sacrifices and
why my video on the subject did so well.
I have no idea if this is true by the way,
it's just my own theory, but yeah, WW2
is definitely the most overrated subject.
-------------------------
@Artur_M.
This might be
a bit silly, but I wonder: how often do
you have to explain where Slovakia is,
what's the difference between it and Slovenia,
or that Czechoslovakia no longer exists?
In Europe I have never met with anyone who
didn’t know where Slovakia was or at least had a
vague idea that it was somewhere south of Poland.
When I lived in the US, however, my god Americans
are allergic to geography, or learning about
other countries, or honestly anything outside
of America. Like 20% of the time I would have
people literally think I just made up a country,
and another 60% of the time I would have to
explain where Slovakia is because they had
absolutely no idea. The Czechoslovakia thing I
didn’t get as much but that’s probably because
I didn’t hang out with older people a lot
since it's usually them who still remember
Czechoslovakia. There were only around
20% of Americans that either knew of
Slovakia or had at least some idea of it.
Interestingly enough though, I never had
many people think Slovakia and Slovenia were
the same country or were confused about it,
it’s just sometimes on forms people would write
down my country as Slovenia rather than Slovakia
but honestly that’s a mistake I have done
before as well. Especially on those scroll
down forms on the internet I sometimes don’t read
it properly and just click Slovenia accidentally,
so I can’t really blame people for
doing the same mistake I sometimes do.
--------------------------------------------------------
@DG-jp8yw
Do you know people who go to
Oxford and Cambridge? What sort of occupations are
they doing now that there isn’t a colonial empire?
Hehe, good question. For those that don’t
get this go watch my Oxford and Empire video,
also for those that don’t know I went to Oxford
and now I am doing a PhD at Cambridge. So,
Oxbridge, that is Oxford and Cambridge together,
are very much modern Universities at this point.
They underwent quite sizeable restructuring in the
latter half of the 20th century as the empire fell
apart, for example, they began to higher a lot
more professors from all around the world not
just from the Empire and they also opened up
the application process to basically anyone,
and they started a lot of outreach programs
which are necessary to help people from less
privileged backgrounds to even understand the
application process because the application
process to Oxbridge is a bit weird. During
this time also all the colleges in Oxbridge
finally started to allow women to
get degrees, which, sidenote here,
the history of women at Oxbridge is fascinating.
The bullshit they had to deal with for hundreds
of years and the arguments they had to withstand
from grumpy old men were just the most ridiculous.
There’s a book about it if you want to know
more. Anyways, due to all these changes and
getting rid of legacy admissions which many high
end universities in America still have, Oxbridge
is quite diverse these days and due to the breadth
of the intake of people from all around the world,
the students here are truly some of the smartest
people in their field and they end up doing all
kinds of jobs after they graduate. But if you
really want to know specifics Oxbridge releases
all the statistics on where their alumni end up.
Between 2012 and 2017 most Oxford alumni ended up
in Academia and Higher Education, but that’s
only 15% with the rest being quite diverse.
-------------------------------------
@denethweerasinghe
Is the stereotype of Oxford PPE students real?
Ok now that we have established that Oxbridge
is quite a diverse place and people end up doing
all kinds of things, let's get into the gossip.
To explain, the Oxford PPE program is a degree
in Philosophy, politics and economics. The
degree was introduced in the 1920s as a more
modern version of Classics which was what most
Oxbridge quote unquote “gentlemen” of the 19th
century took if they wanted to go into politics
or the Imperial or home civil service. Today PPE
is most well known for being the degree that most
future politicians take at Oxford. Harold Wilson,
Edward Heath, David Cameron, Liz Truss and Rishi
Sunak all took PPE at Oxford. It’s usually future
conservative party members that take PPE at
Oxford rather than others so the degree is often,
but not exclusively, associated with posh upper
class people who want to go into politics. And,
this stereotype is honestly true. Although,
most people who took PPE that I met weren’t
pretentious, most of them were nice and didn’t
act like they were better than everyone else,
they were just often ambitious, since they wanted
to go into politics, and quite posh, usually
coming from public schools, but I didn’t find them
to be mean or pretentious or anything. In fact,
I met more pretentious people studying history
than PPE and the subjects that have the most
pretentious people are various business degrees.
These are usually taken by kids of parents who own
companies so they can party and network with other
rich kids while at Oxford and then be given a job
by their parents. Most business students don’t
even really mix with the other students. I lived
with an MBA student while at Oxford so I had the
privilege to observe these people and I think the
best way to summarize it is this quote from The
Spector, ‘attending a mixer at the Said Business
School’, that is what the University of Oxford
Business school is called, ‘is like a United
Nations for the 1 percent. There’s the grandson
of a Greek shipping tycoon; the daughter of a
man who owns a Lithuanian bank; a guy whose
thesis is funded by the Qatari government;
the Saudi brothers who jet in and out weekly from
the Gulf’ and so on. I have to emphasize though,
that in my experience none of them were mean
to me and not all of them were pretentious,
but when I found a non-pretentious person it
was more of a surprise rather than the norm,
and I also wouldn’t call any of them
dumb they were just often out of touch.
---------------------------------------------------
@tacomusical1404
Could you answer,how
to be a self-trained historian?
Read a lot of history books and historical
journal articles about a specific topic
you want to learn about. After you have done
that you can start learning historical theory,
that is the theories behind the various
ways historians approach history.
In my experience, people would talk about
how this book about Czechoslovak history
was written in a very whiggish way or this book
on early medieval Slavic history was written in
a very postmodernist way, and at the time I
didn’t know enough about Czechoslovak history
or Medieval Slavic history to understand what
history they were talking about, let alone the
historical theories they were mentioning.
So my advice is to first just go on google,
search by books, and type in whatever topic
you want to learn about and read a bunch of
those books. After that it wouldn’t hurt to
look at the primary sources the books are
referencing. Ones you have read many of the
books and seen some of the primary sources,
you will notice that even though it’s the same
topic and largely the same primary sources,
unless something new has been discovered, all the
books have a different approach towards the topic
and what you’re noticing is the various historical
theories that the historian who wrote those books
are using to approach the same historical topic.
Once you get to that point you can actually start
reading about historical theory, by buying
and reading the various books on historical
theory (History: An Introduction to Theory, Method
and Practice), and since you already read a lot of
history books beforehand you can understand better
what the historical theories actually look like in
practice. Of course, this wouldn’t really work
with niche topics, like there aren’t many books
on early medieval guilds for example, so it’s
better to start with broader well documented
topics were there are multiple books written
in multiple different ways and than you can
go into these nicher topics and see like ‘ahh in
this one niche topic there’s only this one book
that used this historical approach.’
So, yeah, hopefully that made sense.
---------------------------------------------
@MrPainisCupcake
How do you get into in-depth
history content by professional historians? Do
you think it's a prohibitively expensive hobby?
You get into in-depth history content by reading
history books and articles and getting those books
and articles is 100% prohibitively expensive. For
example, Sources of Slavic Pre-Christian Religion,
costs 180 euros! Don’t get me wrong, the writers
of this book did a lot of work tracking down all
the sources, translating them, and giving
context to them and it is the best book
out there if you want to understand what we
know and more importantly what we don’t know
about Slavic paganism. But my god no one with
institutional financial support will be able
to justify buying this. And I didn’t pick some
random book that happens to be expensive, most
history books which aren’t pop-history books, are
freaking expensive. The multi volume set of The
Cambridge History of Russia costs 111 pounds if
you buy the paperback and over 300 pounds if you
buy the hardcover. Greek Historical Inscriptions
478-404 BC cost 180 pounds, well now you can get
it in paperback for 35 pounds but that’s only
from 2020, I had to pay 180 pounds for it.
Journals also aren’t any better. The Journal of
Slavic Military Studies costs 137 pounds a year,
and if you just want to read one article, no
problem, just pay 37 pounds for 48 hours access
for one 30 paged article. It’s ridiculous.
No wonder academia is disconnected from the
average person when no average person can
afford to read academic publications. Why
is it all so expensive? Well, I haven’t done any
research into it but my guess would be that these
book and journal publishers make money off of
institutional subscriptions. If they make books
and subscriptions, which universities, libraries,
and research institutions need to buy, expensive,
they can justify charging them millions
of dollars. And this is where publishers
make money, £180m are spent annually by
UK universities on journal subscriptions
alone. These are the customers publishers
are aiming for, not individual researchers,
so they make their publications expensive knowing
full well not many individual people will pay for
it but universities, libraries, and research
institutions will pay millions for it. At least
that’s what I think but I am sure there’s
more to the story that I am not aware of.
This whole thing is, however, a problem for
individuals who want to get into history. The
only way an individual can circumvent
it, is by getting a library membership
and hope that the library near you is well
stocked, has enough money to get new books,
and has fairly good coverage of paid journal
articles. Some libraries do have all this,
especially in big cities, and they are amazing
institutions and I recommend paying for a library
membership because they are essential for a
modern society, but not everyone has access to
libraries like these at which point you’re sadly
stuck buying very expensive books and articles.
----------------------------------------------------
@jordanhicken7812
Is going for your PhD in History
something that you would recommend to someone
who is passionate about history and teaching?
I am gonna say what every history professor
I talked to about this told me, and that is
on average NO. But there are exceptions and of
course you always have to consider your personal
situation. On average, however, why most people
say no is because the only job in the world that
requires a PhD in history is to be an academic
historian so the employment market isn’t very big.
Basically, when it comes to a PhD in
history, the fact that you really only
need it for one specific thing means that
you’re better off going into the private
sector with just a masters. When you try
to go into the private sector with a PhD,
employers often think you’re overqualified. Which
is stupid because a PhD shows that you’re capable
of doing extensive learning on your own and
have the capability to learn complex things,
but that’s not how most employers see it.
Therefore, a PhD in history is only really
useful in the academic sector. The problem
with the academic sector is that academic
positions are few and far apart and, because
very rarely are new positions added, you’re
often waiting for old tenure professors to retire
or since a lot of professors aren’t retiring,
even die. Meaning whether you get an academic job
is extremely luck based. Also, in the UK, because
there’s more PhD holders that want academic
positions than there are actual positions, the
current system of academic employment is pretty
broken. The exploitation of non permanent position
academics is part of the reason why the current
university marking boycott is happening in the UK.
There’s also a problem with prestige. When
it comes to learning and making a well made
PhD thesis in history, the supervisor is often
far more important than the institution you’re
at. However, after you graduate, sadly a lot
of employers don’t care about that. From my
experience, someone with fairly mediocre research
and grades who has a doctorate from Oxbridge or
an Ivy League university is far more likely to be
employed than someone who is smarter but is from
a less prestigious university. For example, if you
look at most university history departments in the
UK, most of the professors there have Oxbridge
degrees. I even had a friend who did a masters
with me at Oxford and didn’t get into a funded
doctorate at Oxbridge, Edinburgh, and Durham,
but he did get a fully funded PhD offer at the
University of Southampton, but even though it
was fully funded, he told me it wasn’t worth
taking it because trying to find employment
after finishing a PhD at not so prestigious
university will be very hard. And even though
he really wanted to do a PhD which continued on
his masters research which was very interesting,
he went into the private sector instead because
he was convinced that without a PhD from a top UK
university it would be very hard for him to
find an academic job afterwards. Of course,
this part is all just my experience and what I
have seen and heard from people in the sector,
I have not done any extensive research into this.
Now all of this is based on money which
contrary to what some people on the internet
or in the government believe isn’t the only
driving force for human beings. Of course,
in our current economic system you
need money to survive but there’s
other factors that play into why
someone would want to do a PhD.
Doing a PhD in history, I would argue, is
very intellectually fulfilling and teaches
you a lot of valuable lessons about doing
proper research and how to work on things
that take years to finish. You’re also doing
a PhD in history because you’re passionate
about the subject and there’s many other
people that are doing the same thing and
that you will meet during your PhD and make
lifelong connections with. And from anime
we all know that the power of friendship
is the strongest thing in the universe.
Jokes aside, the bottom line is this.
If you’re a very financially driven
person you shouldn’t do a PhD in history.
If you are in a financially unstable place
you probably shouldn’t do a PhD in history.
If you, however, managed to secure funding
for a PhD, then perhaps consider doing it.
If you are very passionate about the subject
you will research, also consider doing it.
If you manage to get into a prestigious
institution, you should consider doing it.
In the end I can’t tell you outright
whether to do or not to do a PhD in history,
but hopefully I have provided some information
that can help you make a more educated decision.
--------------------------------------------------
@nolancrowe3805
I'd be interested to
hear generally about your experiences in academia.
What are your thoughts on the current
state of history as a discipline?
Could you speak to current trends within
history as a discipline or academia generally?
What do you think of the types of
people you run into in academia?
Alright, so we shall combine all the things
I have said in the previous two responses for
this response. I will continue to talk about
academic history in the UK because that’s
what I know the best, so keep in mind even
though there are many similarities between
academic departments or academic history in
other countries there are also differences.
First, most academics in the UK are male, 72% to
be exact (80% when it comes to History). Which
is probably still a remnant of the fact that some
institutions like Magdalena College at Cambridge
only allowed female students in 1988. Also, most
institutions hire early career academics based
on an annual contract rather than give you a fixed
job which means women don’t get paid maternity
leave and often just lose their contracts
if they have a baby. As one woman put it,
‘It was very weird going on maternity
leave knowing that that was the end of
my job … It’s truly my dream job. And it was a
completely irrational thing, but for a while I
resented the baby because it felt like I
had been forced to give up a job I love.’
Also, as we have discussed, getting into history
as an individual can be quite expensive, and it’s
often not recommended for people to do a PhD in
history unless they are in a financially stable
place. Since full PhD funding for history is very
rare, and everyone in academia must have a PhD,
this means most academic historians,
especially ones in permanent positions,
come from a fairly privileged background. As
a journalist report by The Economist states,
in the UK, due to various reasons, ‘it is far
easier to get a permanent academic job if you
are rich than if you are poor.’ Plus, as we
already discussed, a lot of early academics
are being quite heavily exploited as permanent
positions are very limited and often held by
older academics. This means that a lot of
academic history in the UK is controlled by
older upper middle class men. The kind of people
that don’t deal well with change, or technology,
and I am not talking about political leanings
here, I am talking solely about history,
and trying to implement changes in the field
to keep up with the ever changing world.
A lot of academics I met are set in their
ways, hard to convince to work on new and
different projects, and usually quite defensive
about any kind of change. I cannot blame them
for the latter reason, academic history has
always been attacked by a variety of groups,
especially governments that don’t like historians
who talk about history that paints them in a bad
light. Not to mention that funding for history
has always been limited as people and governments
often don’t find it valuable and so don’t
fund it as much as the sciences. Therefore,
being quite defensive of your job especially when
your source of funding is limited is expected.
On the other hand, however, as my paper
discussed, link to it in the pinned comment,
academic history has become quite disconnected
from the public and some of the research projects
that people are doing can be hard to defend. Of
course in a perfect world I think you should be
able to do any kind of research because it’s all
valuable, but we do not live in a perfect world
and when funding and time is limited it’s hard
to defend someone doing a funded PhD thesis on
I have met academics who lived their entire
lives without considering the greater value
of their work to society other than saying it’s
all intrinsically valuable. There are 60 year
old academics that literally since undergrad
have not left the university and have only
written articles and books that are so niche
and boring only a handful of other academics
have ever read them. That is why I can see
why a lot of people from the outside look
at academic history and then decide history
is useless and don’t give it much funding.
Therefore, there needs to be some kind of
a reimagining of how academic history is
conducted and what are its goals, because clearly
just saying it’s all intrinsically valuable,
no matter how true it may be, doesn’t resonate
with most of the population. Don’t get me wrong,
I often go to bat for academic humanities because
current attacks calling it useless are just not
true, but I am also aware that those attacks
don’t come from nowhere and something needs to
be done to address the source of this sentiment.
Academics need to find another way, other than
saying it’s intrinsically valuable, to showcase
the value of academic history to the public and
not be stuck in their ivory towers, otherwise
the current attacks on academia will only worsen.
------------------------------
@rivets3259
So most people here are asking
real or serious questions, so let me be useless
and ask what your preferred heavy booze is?
BEER!
Ok, jokes aside, I don’t really drink
heavy liquor. I hate all the liquors that’re drunk
in Slovakia like slivovica, borovicka, palenka. My
drinks of choice are usually beer, ale or cider,
that’s about it, I don’t even really like wine,
or champagne. On the rare occasions that I do
drink liquor I just go for a gin and tonic.
-------------------------------
@LaszloSean
Budvar or Urquell? or, Battle
of Slovakia, Bažant or Šariš?
Budvar, hands down, like it’s not even
a competition, and in Slovakia Bazant.
---------------------------------
@NotShady9
Other than
early medieval Eastern Europe what are
your favourite subjects in history?
Ahhh, I see you know my favorite subject
is early medieval Eastern Europe,
I would argue that it’s early medieval
Europe in general not just eastern Europe,
but I do tend to focus on eastern Europe
a lot so fair enough. Other than that,
honestly, depends. It fluctuates quite a bit. Of
course, strong candidates are Classical Greece
and Austria-Hungary. Mexican or Latin American
history in general is a strong second. Recently
I also got really into Spanish history since
that was the most recent place I traveled to,
so yeah, it usually all depends on
what I am doing or reading at the time.
---------------------------------
@NotShady9
Who is your favourite historical figure?
Honestly, probably Masaryk, not because
he was perfect or without flaws,
no one is and he certainly wasn’t, but his
life's trajectory is just interesting to me.
It’s fascinating to me that he taught
himself multiple languages as a kid,
or the fact that at various points in his life
he flirted with pan-Slavism, Habsburg Monarchism,
and republicanism, or the fact that as a leader he
lived through a very tumultuous time and managed
to stay relatively free of controversy. On the
other hand he did have anger issues and he did
publicly forsook his morals a couple of times and
engaged in populist anti-semetic and anti-german
politics because he thought he had to in order to
secure a strong nation, but he never followed up
on these statements and even often contradicted
them with his actions or later apologized for
them, so he was certainly not perfect and he
deserves to be called out. With that said,
I think he was an interesting guy, living at an
interesting time, doing some interesting things.
---------------------------------
@adisor906
What's the most
politically biased history book you've ever read?
Edward Long’s 1774 History of Jamaica. This book
was so racist that it’s honestly impressive.
Long basically wanted to institutionalize slavery
based on race as a “natural order” of things and
through history he tried to very graphically
showcase how Africans were a different,
inferior race and, therefore, should
be slaves. Even for the 18th century,
a lot of people at the time were surprised just
how racist this book was when it was published.
Another really bad book was A History of England
by C.R.L. Fletcher published in 1911 that I quoted
in my Oxford and Empire video. The book was quite
racist in order to justify the British Empire.
What makes that book particularly bad though is
that it was made to be used in primary schools,
and in some parts of England it was used in
primary schools all the way until the 1950s.
I am sure there are many other books that I have
read over the times that are quite bad but those
two stood out to me so much when I read them that
they’re just the first ones that come to mind.
----------------------------
@FencingFella
What are some
myths that Slovak schools teach
as if they were our history?
There’s a lot of myths, most notably when it
comes to 20th century history there’s a lot of
whitewashing (deliberately attempting to conceal
unpleasant or incriminating facts) happening,
but the one thing I hate the most is
unsurprisingly connected to medieval
history. What I am going to talk about is a
mistake almost every European country does,
not just Slovakia, but the question asked
about Slovakia so I will talk about Slovakia.
So, basically the 9th century Great Moravia was
formed when the duchy of Moravia invaded and
conquered the duchy of Nitra. Now this 9th century
Great Moravia is taught in Slovak schools as
having already people who identified as ethnically
Slovak and Czech based on the two duchies i.e.
people living in the Moravian duchy were Czech and
people living in the Nitra duchy were Slovak. The
idea of some kind of a Moravian ethnicity
separate from Czech was never introduced,
at least when I was in school, and Bohemia
was also often incorporated under the whole
Moravian Czech identity. The problem is that
discussing early medieval ethnicity as if it
was the same as our modern concept of ethnicity is
at best inappropriate and at worst just outright
incorrect. Back then ethnicity wasn’t seen as
an important identifier to a person as it does
to us today. People didn’t care as much about what
ethnicity you were as they did about what religion
you were, what legal status you had, what was your
occupation, what leader you followed, etc. That is
why multiethnic kingdoms in the middle ages were
so common, and why prosecution was almost always
based on religion rather than ethnicity. Plus,
the idea of a distinct Slovak ethnicity didn’t
even exist until the early modern period, before
then the people living in the northern part of the
Kingdom of Hungary that spoke a Slavic language
were in documents just called ‘the Slavs’. That is
why talking about the Slavs of the Nitra duchy
as if they were somehow Slovak back then and
identified as Slovak or as a distinct ethnically
separate Slavic group from all the other western
Slavs is just inaccurate. However, part of
an ethnic identity is to have an established
historical narrative for your ethnicity so, if we
want to keep the modern idea of ethnicity we kind
of have to teach about early medieval kingdoms
in terms of having ethnic continuity to today,
and I don’t think the world is ready to abandon
the modern idea of ethnicity any time soon.
------------------------------
@TheRageng
What's your take
on the importance of the Slovak uprising of 1848?
This is a great follow up on the previous question
and how ethnicity wasn’t as important as it is
now. When you look the uprisings in Austria
in 1848, especially the ones in Slovakia,
not only did the quote “Slovak” uprisings have
a lot of people from today’s Czechia in it who
we would call today Czech, but they also were
quite disorganized and there were many Slovak
peasants that fought on the Hungarian side.
The former point shows just how incomplete
the creation of a distinct Slovak ethnic group
was at this point and that the idea that Slovaks
were ethnically separate from Czechs wasn’t
fully developed yet, and the latter point
shows that the official narrative of a united
Slovak rebellion which wanted autonomy for its
ethnic group is just one part of a much greater
story. Yes, there were people like the ones
in Myjava that fought for ethnic autonomy, but
there were many Slovak peasants that fought in
the Hungarian armies which were fighting for the
end of feudal peasantry. As Dusan Kovac states,
‘Slovak peasants were primarily concerned
with the abolition of feudal subjection and
not wider political agenda. Where this
issue connected with the national idea,
many Slovak peasants were persuaded to join
the ranks of the Slovak rebels. In regions
where Magyar revolutionaries had begun to
agitate first, Slovak peasants joined them,
and fought in the ranks of the Magyar national
guards.’ This nuance has been lost in most modern
Slovak retellings of the story and today the
1848 uprising is remembered as ethnic Slovaks
fighting for our ethnic autonomy. When in reality
a lot, although of course not all, Slovak peasants
just didn’t want to be peasants anymore and they
didn’t really care if that was in a Slovak state,
a Hungarian state or an Austrian state. So
what’s the importance of the uprising, well
the 1848 uprisings directly led to the 1849 land
reform in Austria which ended feudal subjection,
so it was very important, it just wasn’t important
in the way we today in Slovakia think it was.
-------------------------------
@history.crusaider
What is your opinion
on Ancient Greek civilizations
and their influence on the world?
Greek influence on Europe, and due to
European Empires also the rest of the world,
is extremely large. Throughout history
Europeans time and time again referred back
to ancient Greek and Roman philosophy, art,
architecture, history and more. From modern
philosophers and historians like Foucault
to renaissance ones like Machiavely to
medieval ones like Albertus Magnus, they all
reference ancient Rome and Greece. Of course,
Roman is not the same as Greek but Romans
did adopt a lot from the Greeks and so many
historians talk about a not singularly Greek or
Roman legacy in Europe but a Greco-Roman one.
Why have, however, Europeans been so obsessed
with Greco-Roman ideas, heritage and more?
Why do we still build classical style buildings,
still reference Plato and Herodotus, make plays,
movies, and video games about Greek mythology
and more? Perhaps it’s because we have so much
still remaining from the Greeks, our alphabet,
our sciences and math, our political ideas like
democracy, and even Christianity has many Greek
aspects. The New Testament was written in Greek,
the word Bible just means ‘the books’
in ancient Greek, and Platonism,
with its ideas like the theory of the soul, was
a huge influence on christian theology. Also,
the earliest ideas of European political theory
come from ancient Greece and so does the idea of
citizenship, because it was in the Greek polis
that politics were first recorded and people
identified as citizens of a specific citystate.
Of course, Europeans and also the ancient Greeks
and Romans didn’t develop all this in a vacuum and
there were influences from Egypt, Persia, India,
etc. but, it was the Greeks and later Romans
not others, that specifically influenced our
corner of the world the most and so it’s their
philosophy, art, architecture, science, math,
etc. that are still present today in much of our
language, politics, science and more. With that
said, this influence also includes bad ideas, like
the Greco-Roman idea of a very strong patriarchy,
which is something we still are trying to shake
to this day. However, because there still is so
much in our modern European world that can be
traced back to the Greeks and Romans it perhaps
should not be surprising that we still refer back
to them so much. If you want to know more about
this topic there’s a good book on the subject
called The Legacy of Greece : a new appraisal.
My personal interest in Ancient Greece comes
from purely the fact that I want to understand
the history, and historical context that
all these ideas we talked about originated
from. I also find it funny how a lot of the
politics of the time are quite similar to
our modern politics even though they're
2500 years apart. It helps me, I think,
realize many important things applicable to
today. For example, it helped me realize that
democracy is quite fragile and that if left
unprotected people like the conservatives of
the Areopagus can exploit certain imperfect
systems within democracy to take control
of the state. Similar to what some people
have or are trying to do in our modern times.
-------------------------------
@TitusDux
How do you choose your video
topics? Because all the videos after your last
Q&A go from 400s bc Greece all the way to almost
modern times. Is it "I'm currently reading a book
that's really interesting so I'll make a video?
It’s a combination of multiple things.
A lot of the time it is just that I am
reading something interesting and I want to make
a video about it. My Aztec human sacrifices video
was inspired by a journal article and my Charles
the V video was inspired by a biography I read
about him. However, other times it might be
something more, like my Athenian Empire series
is inspired by this very good history class
about the Athenian Empire I took at Birkbeck,
and I just wanted to know more about it and
making a video series is a great excuse to
read more into it. In fact, some of my videos
are just topics I want to know more about,
like European Warrior Maidens or Oxford and
Empire, so I kind of justify wasting time
on researching those topics by also making a
video about it. Lastly, some of my videos like
my Viennese Coffee Houses History or Lichtenstein
gaining a soldier in a war, are purely just topics
I read about somewhere and thought they
would do well with the YouTube algorithm.
-----------------------------------------------
@TitusDux
History of Romania when?
Ok there is a very vocal Romanian crowd wanting a
history of Romania and I hear you but as you have
probably noticed during this QnA, ethnicity is
complicated, and I want to first make a video on
early medieval ethnicity before I start discussing
more medieval ethnic groups like Romania. However,
because it is complicated, the video is very
hard to make and I need to get a DNA expert
to talk about how using DNA for defining
ethnicity in Europe is not inconclusive,
which is what many people think it is, and
that there are actually many problems with
the methodology used for DNA studies
that are very rarely discussed. Now,
I have some people in mind that I
could talk to about this but it is
a long process and I am also doing a PhD on
the side so it’s all gonna take a long time.
---------------------------------------------
@SlovakFella
If you could have a dinner with any historical
character (brought back to life at age of your
choosing), which ones would you want to meet?
Oh my god there’s so many. I want to talk to
Samo, the one who established the Slavic Samo’s
Confederation, or anyone who ruled Moravia in the
9th century, or maybe Bayan the first Khagna of
the Avar Khaganate and ask him all kinds of
questions from what he thinks of the Slavs
living in his state to where did he come from,
is he descended from the Rouran or not? But if
I had to choose one person, it would probably be
Cassiodorus, so I can question him on his lost 14
volume book on the history of the Goths, and also
since he was a historical writer I could probably
get the most historical information out of him
compared to all the other people I mentioned.
----------------------------
@tenebrousoul9368
Peanut butter: crunchy or
smooth? You have to pick one.
Uuu, controversial, but I’ll do you
one better, I don’t like peanut butter.
------------------------------------
@Gazda
Lastly: ‘How are you ?’
Ehhh, ever since covid it’s been a bit of a
shitshow. Personal health hasn’t been great,
at the time of writing this I am struggling
with long covid, also geopolitics are a mess,
there’s people I used to play doubles
tennis with that are now in an active war.
It’s crazy … But, I guess, all I try to do
is just- one step at a time, one day at time,
make my little corner of the world better and
that’s kind of all you can do most of the time.
---------------------------------
Thank you so much for watching my QnA,
hopefully some of it was helpful and
interesting. If you like what I do please
consider supporting on Patreon because,
honestly, without Patreon support I wouldn’t
be able to do what I do right now. Therefore,
I would like to give special thanks to all
my Patreons as now that I am starting a PhD
which isn’t fully funded the financial
support is tremendously appreciated and
very helpful. As always, special thanks to my
deity tier Patreons; Rohan, Crafty Criminalist,
Bryan Lafata, and Nick Jasperse. My name is
Matus Laser and stick around for history.